the sheen on the water is clue that
there's fuel on its surface 200 barrels
of it leaked into pool Harbor from an
onshore pipeline The Spill contained by
these floating barriers part of a major
operation to try to limit the pollution
we've got helicopters we've got drones
we've got foot patrols as well in order
to collect as much information and data
and feed that back to the emergency
control center here at pool Harbor how
serious is it it's not as serious as we
initially feared I do think it's a full
investigation should be carried out to
ensure that we understand how this event
took place and to make sure that steps
are put in place to prevent it happening
again the company which runs the oil
field to perenco says the situation is
now under control but there are concerns
about the impact on the wildlife here
pool Harbor is a nature conservation
site one of Europe's largest natural
harbors and home to vibrant bird and
marine life and while authorities say
The Spill is reducing it's clear the
threat is not over yet
pool Harbor here behind me would usually
be packed with people paddle boarding
doing water sports but the public has
been told to stay out of the water and
if they come into contact with a spill
they should wash with soap and water
those who live here want answers about
what the consequences will be a lot of
people have been worried about drilling
going on here over the years anyway but
they've got a duty of care to look after
a naturally beautiful area well the
businesses that rely on it are going to
lose vast amounts of money because
nobody's allowed into the harbor wants
to take the risk we do a lot of water
sports we've got a couple of boats that
we use and the harbor is our life so yes
obviously very upset
tellers there's going to be no lasting
damage I hope they're right
the cause of the league is still unknown
but an investigation is underway to
determine how a fuel spill could happen
in this most delicate of ecosystems
Sky News pool